this is middleton in greater manchester
birthplace of thomas langley the
longest-serving chancellor of the
exchequer of the middle ages so 700
years later did the tax cuts proposed by
prime ministerial contenders here feel
like a priority i think there's other
issues that are a little bit more
important to be honest you see
veterans on the street
you know all people that can't afford to
have
the electric on and like we were saying
the other day it's getting it's going up
again the electrics the gas where does
it stop people can't afford it people
will
they'll end up finding people dead in
the houses because they're frozen to
death they can't cut the taxes as much
as you need to because all the debt's
got to be paid back you know billions of
pounds for
obviously the colbid which was no fault
of anybody's
haircuts are joanna hess's business she
says tax cuts would help at a time when
she's having to raise prices and turn
down young apprentices almost every week
i get the college is calling me they've
got this apprentice and things like that
i had to say to them no i can't
obviously afford because
you know
you're not having them free you still
have to pay them you know a wage i think
if i can get a bit more help
i will be able to help more people so
definitely bringing down corporation tax
and
national insurance will will help a lot
will help a lot joanna says that a
leader that helped lower tax would have
her vote but the mortons who both work
in the public sector worry that tax cuts
for all mean spending cuts in services
like education
a lot of people feel like they can't
trust the
conservative government at the moment
with the promises they're making
i think there'll be more services within
um
further education and high schools even
putting her through and through nursery
is really expensive but on the other
side of that the future she's going to
be in a class of
i don't know how many is nowadays but
yeah i'm i'm worried for her future i
mean you do worry for it don't you
really really do they say all that's
certain in life is death and taxes but
here it's futures and opportunities on
which they want more guarantees
catering autopsy sky news in greater
manchester